tous les deux je n'ai selon les calculs
et parce qu'ils cliquent bien trempé 67
ce faisant elle m'attend sané vainement
alors qu'ils en vain en septembre pour
trouver dans les longues pièces avec
violette pour voir mes classes et l'inde
- oui mais appelé surprise aussi parce
que je m'y attendais pas je ne savais
pas dans une émission à bellemare a oui
mais vous n'êtes plus parler au
téléphone je lui écris moi je suis assez
lui relate libraire trouvait trop dur
dans la page est tournée
la chapelle est tournée mais le bouquin
et là ça vous a manqué qui vous appelle
pas
[Musique]
on peut tout dire un à cette heure là
je suis un peu surprise après bon et
qu'est ce qu'on dit quand on se voit
comme ça tu en parles quoi du danemark
je pense pas ou jamais vécu au danemark
boeuf lamente le danemark
de quoi vous savez une fois qu'ils
avaient quittée quitté ma mère c'était
c'était jean luc mon mari c'était aussi
un peu mon père mon frère et puisqu'il
se terminait après ce clip ligne et
détournement de mineure non mais t'as
tes temps je dirais pas vous étiez
consentante tournage tourne on tourne en
la mineur vous ai fait combien de films
alors les jeunes mineurs ouais j'ai fait
sept films et demi c'est lui parce qu'il
ya un sketch à oui ça compte pour une
moitié oui tu as fait tes où on a fait
ces données fais ça tu prends cette
fille cette fille est un sketch c'est
une vie alors jean louis - kst lt
comment comme actrice anna à formidable
formidable la difficulté pense pour
laval en tant que crime que critique aux
journalistes comme vous c'est que les
peut-être sa difficulté comme tant
d'autres je crois en à particulier le
cinéma n'était déjà plus ce qu'il
devrait être
pour que des gens comme ça puisse
travailler lors
cry et hollywood mais on est plus ce qu
il était donc c'est l'europe balle à
cette puissance comme ça c'est une
actrice
si on considère ce qu'il faut au moins
d'un an des loges enfin c'est une
actrice du muet c'est à dire qui c'est
qui peut parler sans qu'on comprenne et
on comprend tout ce qu'avait losc avait
ce qu'avait de l'uel ou une actrice
musical aussi donc dans la série des
grands paradoxes de grave déclare
effectivement que les gens étaient déçus
quand le parlant est arrivé que quand
beaumont avait lancé sont parlants
personne ne voulait y aller non envers
l'époque où lumière a fait le grand café
étaient tous en concurrence edison aussi
edison a présenté un jour à paris le un
cinéma par modèle de cinéma parlant et
ça n'a pas pris
je crois que d'être tous les gens
étaient contents de pouvoir écouter
entendre quelque chose ça les touche et
plus je veux dire si la peinture et
parlant s'il est là ce qu'est ce ce même
parlé à quelle horreur voilà paris dans
cette horreur
alors comme épouse a été commencée pas
dur de maintenant je veux être
c'est quand même de faire tourner
quelques uns et le soir de se retrouver
la maison ensemble ça que je veux dire
il voyage beaucoup j'en ai qu avant ils
étaient très tournés tout le temps ouais
il était tout le temps
s'ensuit une association comme ça je
pense pas qu'on ait vraiment une
fâcheuse mêmes tofu
quand même marché ambiance ophuls
vivaient dans ses films mais c'est une
erreur mais d'une erreur séduisant qu'il
est probablement vu ça de ma femme moi
j'étais trop jeune
le cinéma commence qu'à 30 ans j'étais
heureux et finalement pensé qu'il
fallait aimer parce que j'avais lu oui
on pensait le manque d'amour ans qu'il
faut avoir un grand amour n'en est pas
capable les femmes beaucoup les fans oui
c'est ce que j'avais des bleus
l on souffre certainement et moi tout ce
que je pouvais donner c'est des films
mais les moments un film on sait et
c'est rien est ce à cause de ça vous
êtes quitter finalement c'est parce que
vous n'aviez pas assez à lui donner
traitement et puis franck avait aussi
moi je copiais donc je voulais faire je
me dirais moi après tout il ya des
arsenaux lcd world in berlin dietrich
renoir et catherine hesling lorsque j'ai
moi aussi donc c'est un modèle eh bien
on voit que
après bon ce modèle permet de faire
certains films et puis que les films
après ont du mal à repasser dans dans la
vie et que ça jamais bien bien marché
est-ce qu'on peut être aussi heureux
après parce que ce grand amour ont
concerné petit pharamin s'atténue non
mais je comprends moi je pense qu'on
peut l'être alors beaucoup plus avec de
demain et toujours
[Musique]
les blessés
le vietnam dont on peut pas moi je
pleure pas chez moi
n'at il s'appelle comment votre chien
c'est une chaîne la guyane qui s'appelle
le là parce que j'ai tourné un film
l'appât qui s'appelle cayenne palace et
vous l'avez recueillies pendant le mois
sacré c'est comme si on m'appelle comme
je m'appelais le la dans le film
s'appelle cela vous fait quoi dans ce
film là bas je suis une espèce de
maquerelle oui avec jean yanne richa
périlleux
et puis il ya aussi olivia brunaux il ya
les habite et l'udc
vous avez tous les paiements en même
temps sur les écrans des soins et à
droite et acadiennes palace en même
temps jean lutte vous pensiez on va
rester à droite vous avez pas vu encore
je sais bien si elle arrive koch dense
et très bien vous ai pas vus cayenne pas
l'assemblée vos noms j'irai le voir
sheehan apple oui je savais pas et
lierait qu'est ce que vous pensez des
films que fait on a depuis qu'elle
tourne plus avec vous les gens n'aient
pas vu
n'ai pas eu beaucoup je vais beaucoup
moins au cinéma vu que j'habite il ya
qu'à paris qu'on voit des films beaucoup
de finition si on veut ailleurs ils
viennent plus difficilement ou alors
c'est les grands films américains qu'on
ne veut pas voir comme ça
et votre mode carrière où les diriger
commandes mais vous savez je pense que
on dirige pas spécialement intérieur je
pense qu'il ya aussi des propositions
ont fait un choix parmi est ce qu'on
vous propose alors parfois on propose le
rien très très bien et parfois on pose
quelque chose formidable comme dernier à
moss vient de terminer un tournage avec
entrée tvo l'oeuvre au noir
après marion rolland
rigueur c'est rare s'il vient d'ailleurs
à juste mourir equal oeuvre noire une
oeuvre noire c'est à celle ci leur
dignité
c'est beau avec sursis
bush
c'est avec quelques uns de maria volonté
en fayard il ya beaucoup de monde si
philippe léotard
ça me ferait ça me fera du mieux il ya
mathieu carrière il ya marie france
pisier marie christine barrault il ya
j'en oublie certainement qu'à 60 ans et
non non on vient juste je tiens mes
futurs nageurs 10 juin et non je pense
que ça sera un très très beau fils et
puis j'aime beaucoup d'éloges pour
tourner avec lui c'est un homme très
très calme et très très très très bien
oui tournée ou en belgique dans des
châteaux
ça se passe au moyen âge et c'est un
rôle assez dramatique vu que tu
gouvernante qui te vient complètement
folle à la fin c'est un rôle très
spectaculaire il faut combien de temps
pour se remettre d'un tournage
ça dépend ça dépend ça d'effondrement
mais c'est pas là c'est vrai convient
encore un peu dans son personnage
maintenant après lors du non semble
assez dépeint aussi des films maintenu
comme le renoir par exemple mais là
c'est ça s'apprend certainement plus de
temps de s'en sortir parce que il y à
aussi et aussi le fait que madrid sur
scénario mourir et qui s'ajouté s'il
faudra huit ans oui voilà
[Musique]
biden
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu